bienvenido a esa economía me acompaña en
el estudio daniel hablando de medellín
para el mundo para que no vaya aquí
conflicto con nosotros con fajines jazz
comenzamos con afganistán la crisis se
deja a muchos al amparo de la producción
de narcóticos en este país hola santiago
pues muy bien reivindicado según la
oficina de naciones unidas contra la
droga y el delito afganistán controla
más del 80 por ciento del suministro
mundial de opio la oficina informó que
los talibanes ganaron más de 400
millones de dólares entre 2018 y 2019
por el tráfico de drogas un rubro que
representa hasta el 60 por ciento de sus
ingresos anuales incluso durante la
crisis generada por la pandemia del cob
y 19 el cultivo de amapola se disparó en
un 37 por ciento la onu aseguró que en
2019 la economía del opio generaba entre
1.200 millones y 2100 millones de
dólares anuales en contraste con los 500
millones al año que eeuu daba en ayuda
humanitaria ese mismo año la producción
de ilícitos generó cerca de 120 mil
puestos de trabajo finalizó diciendo que
la producción de opio es tan gran que
contribuye al 11 por ciento de la
economía del país según ese mismo
organismo pasamos ahora a bolivia en
nuestra región este país reportó un leve
descenso en el índice de desempleo algo
positivo claro que si santiago pues la
etapa de la tasa de desocupación en este
país suramericano llegó a su punto más
alto desde que inició la pandemia en
julio de 2020 cuando era cerca del 11,6
por ciento según el instituto de
estadística como vamos a ver en el
gráfico antes de que iniciara la crisis
del desempleo en este país será del 4,5
por ciento uno de los más bajos de la
región en julio pasado casi un año y
medio después las cifras se estabilizó
en poco más del 6% un punto menos que el
mes anterior aunque sigue por encima de
la etapa prepandémica y es que en los
primeros meses de este año bolivia
comenzó a mostrar signos de recuperación
en su economía
principalmente en sectores como la
construcción minería hidrocarburos y
manufacturas daniela pasamos ahora a
francia este país a partir de hoy lunes
comenzó a exigirle el pasaporte
sanitario a los empleos tienen que
interactuar con los clientes
exactamente pues el gobierno de manuel
macro ni exige que desde este lunes 18
millones de empleados que tienen
contacto con público cuenten con el pase
sanitario la medida afecta a
trabajadores de bares restaurantes cines
teatros museos gimnasios e instalaciones
deportivas entre otros el empresario o
administrador que incumpla santiago se
expone a una pena de un año de prisión
ya una multa de 9.000 euros pues el pase
sanitario que ese es un documento que
certifica que la persona está vacunada
que superó el cob y seis meses atrás o
que dio negativo a un test con vigencia
de 72 horas hay sindicatos de
trabajadores que denuncian que el pase
puede ser una fuente de discriminación
para los empleados pero el gobierno lo
niega es todo un experimento cuando
miramos la solicitud del pase de salud
efectivamente un impacto al inicio de la
aplicación de este pase para ciertas
actividades
estoy pensando por ejemplo en parques de
atracciones cines y ciertas actividades
culturales pero las cosas regresaron a
la norma muy rápidamente y hoy las
cifras relativas a las transacciones con
tarjeta de débito son sumamente claras
el pase de salud no tiene impacto en la
actividad económica del país con una o
dos excepciones como los centros
comerciales y llegó el fin de la
gasolina con plomo en el mundo noticia
positiva para el medio ambiente así por
lo menos lo proclamó la organización de
naciones unidas- santiago después de que
las estaciones de servicio de argelia
dejarán de suministrar ese combustible
el pasado mes de julio ese será el
último país que lo tenía desde 1922 el
uso de plomo había sido utilizado como
aditivo de la gasolina para mejorar el
rendimiento del motor pero para naciones
unidas- esto ha sido una catástrofe para
el medio ambiente y para la salud
pública el combustible causa
enfermedades cardíacas y cáncer y
también afecta al desarrollo del cerebro
en especial de los niños la onu estima
que la medida prevendrá 12 millones de
muertes prematuras cada año y que habrá
un ahorro en la economía mundial de
2.400 millones de dólares pasamos ahora
a las bolsas cómo les fue a los
principales parqués a lo largo y ancho
del planeta wall street del cerró mixto
con récords en el standard and poor's
así como en el índice tecnológico nasdaq
encaminados a cerrar un muy buen agosto
veremos como sucede este martes en
américa latina la bolsa de buenos aires
cerró al alza gracias al anuncio de que
la provincia de buenos aires- canjeará
el 98 por ciento de su deuda en moneda
extranjera santiago muchas gracias
daniela por esta actualización del mundo
económico es todo por el momento buenas
noches
[Música]